hemos pasado ya un par de vídeos
hablando de enzimas y lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es entrar en un poco
más de detalle y enfocarnos en algunos
de los factores que ayudan a las enzimas
y como recordatorio las enzimas están
ahí para ayudar a que las reacciones
procedan a bajar sus energías de
activación para hacer que las reacciones
ocurran con más frecuencia o que sucedan
más rápido ya hemos visto ejemplos de
enzimas y sólo para que quede más claro
a veces en un libro de texto verás una
enzima de esta forma verás un dibujo
como este y le van a llamar a esto la
enzima
y luego van a decir que está actuando
sobre algún tipo de sustrato por aquí y
esto es bueno para dar una idea de lo
que ocurre la idea de un sustrato
embonando con una enzima así pero en
realidad así no es como se ve en un
sistema biológico tenemos que recordar
que cuando se habla de enzimas se está
hablando de proteínas ahora bien también
existen este tipo de enzimas de arn
llamadas ribosomas pero por lo general
cuando estamos hablando de enzimas
tendemos a estar hablando de proteínas
y nos pasamos mucho tiempo hablando de
como las proteínas son estas estructuras
estos polipéptidos y todas las cadenas
laterales de los diversos aminoácidos
que pliegan a las proteínas en todo tipo
de diferentes maneras así que un dibujo
más adecuado para algo como esto sería
esta proteína que está doblada de
diferentes maneras quizá tiene algunas
hélices alfa aquí y tal vez tiene
algunas láminas beta por aquí
y el sustrato podría hacer algún tipo de
molécula que se incrusta en la proteína
y vemos algunos ejemplos por aquí esto
es en realidad un modelo de la exo
quinasa y se puede ver un poco del atp
justo ahí y es un poco más difícil de
ver la glucosa que va a ser fosforilada
esta reacción está siendo facilitada por
esta gran estructura proteica 'likes' o
quinasa en lo que nos vamos a enfocar en
este vídeo es que cuando hablamos de una
enzima estamos hablando de proteínas
estamos hablando de una cadena de
aminoácidos pero a menudo hay otras
partes de la enzima que no son
oficialmente proteínas incluso vimos que
cuando hablamos de exo quinasas cuando
hablamos de la fosforilación de la
glucosa dijimos que la forma en que
disminuye la energía de activación es
mediante estos iones de magnesio
positivos
estos iones de magnesio positivos que
permiten mantener a los electrones en
los grupos fosfato un poco ocupados y
alejarlos de modo que este grupo
hidroxilo por aquí se pueda unir con
este fosfato y no tener interferencia
con estos electrones bueno estos iones
de magnesio por aquí no son oficialmente
parte de la proteína estos son lo que
llamamos cofactores así que es posible
que tengas un cofactor justo ahí que se
enganche con la proteína para
convertirse en parte de la enzima y en
realidad si se necesita que esto suceda
para que la reacción ocurra ya que está
desempeñando un papel crucial otro
dibujo que puedes encontrar en algún
libro de texto se verá algo como esto
y dirán bien para que esta reacción
tenga lugar si se necesita tener el
sustrato pero también se necesita tener
el cofactor
como factor
y una vez más suena como una palabra
complicada pero lo que significa es que
se trata de una parte no proteica de la
enzima es otra molécula o jon o átomo
que permite que la enzima realice su
función y que no es formalmente una
parte de un aminoácido o una parte de
una cadena lateral o parte de la
proteína es otra cosa que necesita estar
allí para ayudar a catalizar la reacción
es justo lo que vimos con la ex- equinas
a teníamos iones de magnesio que el
complejo proteico adquiere y es por eso
que cuando la gente habla acerca de sus
vitaminas y minerales una gran cantidad
de vitaminas y minerales que necesitamos
en realidad actúan como cofactores para
las enzimas y así puedes ver en este
dibujo de aquí estos son los bienes de
magnesio en color verde y estos son
cofactores
estos son
dos factores
así que um cofactor es una parte no
proteica de la enzima y podemos
subdividir a los cofactores aún más
podemos dividirlos en con factores
orgánicos y cofactores inorgánicos hemos
visto a los cofactores inorgánicos una
gran cantidad de ellos son guiones verás
iones de magnesio verás iones de sodio
iones de calcio verás todo tipo de cosas
que actúan como cofactores muchas veces
para distraer a los electrones o para
mantenerlos ocupados de manera que el
sustrato pueda acercarse pero también
hay cofactores orgánicos también puede
haber moléculas orgánicas recuerda que
las moléculas orgánicas son aquellas que
están compuestas principalmente por
cadenas de carbono y a los cofactores
que son moléculas orgánicas los llamamos
con enzimas
en cimas
y hay un montón de ejemplos de ccoo
enzimas este de aquí es la enzima
lactato deshidrogenasa y tiene una
coenzima y verás esta coenzima muy
seguido si estudias biología es enea de
justo aquí y esta no es sólo un guión es
una molécula y está compuesta
principalmente por carbono y es por eso
que decimos que es orgánica y no es
formalmente parte de la proteína no es
parte de los aminoácidos que componen a
la proteína y eso es lo que hace que sea
un factor y ya que es una molécula
orgánica la llamamos coenzima
com
encima
pero como cualquier factor su papel es
permitir que la enzima desarrolle su
función que es facilitar una reacción y
esta coenzima en particular enea de que
vas a ver mucho ayuda a facilitar la
transferencia de iones y duro
los iones hidruro rara vez existen por
sí mismos ya que es un hidrógeno con un
electrón extra por lo que tiene una
carga negativa por lo que permite la
transferencia de este grupo a partir de
un sustrato o a un sustrato y eso ocurre
debido a que en él puede aceptar una
unión y duro y convertirse en n ade h
y si quieres ver su estructura con más
detalle que en realidad es fascinante
probablemente voy a hacer todo un vídeo
acerca de n a d
lo que puede hacer esta molécula es
recoger el and johnny duro por aquí en
este carbono y formar otro enlace con el
hidrógeno y te mostraré el mecanismo
completo en otro vídeo ya que el
objetivo de este vídeo es ver co enzimas
sin embargo vemos estos patrones a lo
largo de la biología porque el nombre
nicotina me da adenina y nucleótido
describe exactamente lo que es la
nicotina me da es esta parte de la
molécula
y esta es la parte que puede aceptar un
hidruro o donar un hidruro por lo que se
podría decir que es la parte activa de
la molécula adenina vemos adenina en el
adn en el arn y en el atp por lo que
esta es nuestra buena amiga adenina
justo aquí y dice un nucleótido porque
en realidad tenemos dos nucleótidos
unidos a través de sus grupos fosfatos y
hay un par de maneras interesantes de
pensar en esto tienes una adenina por
aquí tienes una ribosa tienes un grupo
fosfato y si solo miras esta parte por
aquí justo aquí
este podría ser un componente básico del
arn
si hubiera una adenina justo ahí y si
incluimos todo esto permítanme borrar
esta parte
si se incluye todo esto esto es a dp y
la razón por la que se llama de
nucleótido es que también se puede
dividir hacia el otro lado
podemos decir muy bien tenemos un
nucleótido que tiene nicotina me da por
aquí por lo que este es uno de los
nucleótidos y después el otro nucleótido
está justo aquí el que tiene adenina es
por eso que se les llama de nucleótidos
así que espero que esto haga del inea de
una molécula menos misteriosa la vamos a
ver a detalle en el futuro pero me gusta
analizarla porque tiene todos estos
componentes que se pueden encontrar una
y otra vez los ves en el atp los ves en
el arn una y otra vez pero este no es el
único factor o coenzima hay muchos
muchos otros de hecho cuando la gente te
aconseja tomar tus vitaminas y minerales
tiende a hacer porque son cofactores la
vitamina c es un factor muy importante
que está involucrado con las enzimas
aquí tenemos dos modelos diferentes de
la vitamina c tenemos un modelo de
espacio lleno y aquí hay un modelo de
barras y esferas de la vitamina c el
ácido fólico una vez más hay dos modelos
diferentes y estos son co enzimas que
trabajan de manera similar si tenemos
una proteína por aquí que como sabemos
es una estructura muy compleja y tenemos
algunos
2 que serían nuestros reactivos que
necesitan de la enzima para poder llevar
a cabo su reacción la enzima cataliza la
reacción
pero entonces podríamos tener algunos
guiones y puedes ver a los iones como
cofactores y podríamos tener con
factores orgánicos como la vitamina c o
algunos otros de los que hemos hablado
que también están involucrados y ayudan
a facilitar la reacción
y una vez más a veces puede ser que
ayuden a estabilizar la carga a veces
pueden actuar como aceptar eso donadores
de electrones o toda una serie de cosas
diferentes de hecho pueden actuar como
parte del mecanismo de reacción